partnership that has been working these
fields for decades he grows wheat
rapeseed and rye near you to walk in the
state of Brandenburg much of the 260
hectares he farms is leased but now
investors are increasingly taking over
neighboring fields and the farmers are
furious feeling stagnant that means the
price is for leasing and buying land or
rising for us and it's also worried
someone more and more land is in the
hand of outsiders them visit fed
investors are increasingly expanding
into farmers azaria here it's a company
that actually makes furniture but the
business now owns farmland the size of a
large city in Brandenburg alone
investors now own tens of thousands of
hectares of farmland according to
Reinhardt young for the managing
director of the state's farmers
association it's a threat to their means
of making a living I think there's a
kind of locust infestation across the
state but the focus is on areas like the
northern Pregnant's along the highways
Yorker mark region the orderbook
riverscape the most fertile land in
Brandenburg over the past five years
prices have easily doubled what does
that mean for the farmers to pay the
price or they lose the land and indeed
big money has now discovered agriculture
the financial crisis and low interest
rates have drawn investors to investment
companies like here in Hamburg they
advertise farmland as a promising
venture dr. Chavez food agriculture is
an attractive prospect for investors
activist team from the point of view of
investor it represents a class of asset
in a portfolio from which one can expect
a great deal stability to be sure it
doesn't provide the highest dividends
but it does represent a secure long-term
investment because they should this
investment dashed in large-scale
investment is underway in eastern
Germany in particular and it was the
East German socialists of all people who
laid the groundwork for the current
boom in capitalist investment there by
expropriating the farmers and large
landowners the East German leadership
created massive tracts of land for
agricultural cooperatives which employed
tens of thousands of farmers after
German unification in 1990 the federal
government took over the land it offered
it for sale but only a few local farmers
took advantage many of them were driven
out by the old agricultural Kadri's so
enormous tracts of land are still in the
hands of former East German leaders the
old networks are of course all getting
older and the classic case is that a
former head of a cooperative gets a
golden handshake and heads off on a
cruise and then the gentleman with the
big wallets arrived from Hamburg and
says farmer shuts ax the new bosses are
only interested in profits the result is
that on Brandenburg's fields it's no
longer about growing food the unfilled
their goal is to produce electricity and
biogas plants and they generally need a
lot of corn corn was grown here last
year and presumably it will be planted
this year again when your boyfriend
the profits end up at the headquarters
of the big investors and there's less
money staying in the farming regions
result is that more people are moving
away from villages that have already
been dying slowly for years the
expansion of agribusiness is speeding up
that process that took the rate of
capital investors into these regions is
plundering the countryside that leads to
the village is dying out and young
people moving away up that's a terrible
development and the farmers want to
fight it seems there's a desire to
resist that in Berlin to the new
government's coalition contract contains
a pledge to investigate the buying of
agricultural land by investors but in
practice just the opposite is happening
with a mandate from the finance minister
the bv v g the government supported
company tasked with administering the
land once held by the East German
government has been selling it to the
highest bidder yeah for call we sell to
those who participate in the bidding
Biocon in concert and that would be the
highest bidder condition yes of course
the CDU's agriculture expert doesn't
agree with the long-standing practices
of the finance minister stunt admitted
fault the point of it was revenue attack
yeah getting the highest possible
revenue for the Treasury because that
was the assignment that's the Dethklok
I've spoken with many in the b VV g who
were very unhappy about the pressure put
on them by the finance ministry deal
it's the funky 19 is damn come on so the
prices for farmland continued to rise no
problem for financially strong capital
investors in addition the European Union
adds up to 300 euros per hectare
annually that can add up to another
couple of million more with large tracts
much to the joy of the investors in
Stalag with urban real estate investment
there's already definite talk about a
bubble that means that there aren't
enough investment possibilities in
relation to the money that's there and
looking for a place to invest that's
different in agriculture so we believe
that we offer an interesting alternative
which could remain interesting for the
next few years implus on zion couldnt
but those next few years are a cause for
concern for farmer schütze his family
has been farming here since medieval
times but if things continue as they are
now his generation could be the last
you